أدخلني مفتاح الغرفة هذا إلى الغرفة ، لكنه
لا يعمل إلا مرة واحدة ، لذا بمجرد وصولي لا
يمكنني المغادرة ، أغادر اليابان متوجهًا إلى
هونغ كونغ وأقوم بشيء
لا يفعله معظم الناس الآن وهو
السفر دوليًا و  ثم
هناك أمر الحجر الصحي الإجباري هذا ،
ما يعنيه ذلك هو أنه أينما
أخبر الحكومة أنني سأبقى ،
لا أصدق أنه لا يمكنني
حتى الخروج من الباب لمدة 14
يومًا ، فهذه هي مدى صرامة هونغ كونغ مع هذا
الحجر الصحي.  m الآن خارج رحلتي
ومتجهًا إلى الموقع حيث سنخضع
جميعًا لاختبار فيروس كورونا
لأننا وصلنا في ساعة معينة
اليوم لا يمكنهم معالجة الاختبارات اليوم ،
لذا سيتعين علينا قضاء الليل في
مكان آخر بعد ذلك  انتظر نتائج الاختبار الخاصة بنا
، ثم إذا كان الاختبار سلبيًا ،
فسنبدأ في
الحجر الصحي الإجباري ، هذا هو
سوار معصم إلكتروني ، أنت تعرف نوع استخدامه
لمراقبة الأشخاص الذين يخضعون للإقامة
الجبرية ولكن علي ارتداء هذا لمدة
14 يومًا القادمة  بيك  هذه هي الطريقة التي ستتبعها
الحكومة لتتبع موقعي
، لقد تلقيت هذه الحقيبة ، هذا هو
اختبار Cova 19 الذي سأديره
بنفسي ، سأقوم بأخذ عينة
من لعابي
الآن في الفندق التالي الذي أقوم به  الغرفة
التي توفرها حكومة هونغ كونغ حيث
سأجلس الآن وأنتظر مكالمة هاتفية على
هذا الهاتف وآمل أن تخبرني
بأنني أجريت اختبارًا سلبيًا في هذه الحالة ، ثم يمكنني أن أبدأ الحجر الصحي الإجباري لمدة 14 يومًا إذا اختبرت عودة إيجابية قاطعة ، ثم
يتعين علي أن  أحضر سيارة إسعاف واذهب إلى
المستشفى ، أدخلني مفتاح الغرفة هذا إلى
الغرفة ولكنه يعمل مرة واحدة فقط ، لذا بمجرد وصولي
لا يمكنني المغادرة ، تركوا
الإفطار خارج باب منزلي على الأقل وهم
يأكلون مرحبًا ، حسنًا ، ما الذي اعتاد  ستكون
رحلة مدتها خمس ساعات قبل أن يتحول الفيروس التاجي الآن
إلى رحلة مدتها عشرين ساعة بالإضافة
إلى الأسبوعين المقبلين في الحجر الصحي المنزلي ،
لكنني ممتن لأنني في المنزل
[موسيقى]